الانقسامات تحوم بالحلف من الخارج وايضا
من الداخل حيث ان الخلاف اشتد بين اعضائه
حول تسليم اوكرانيا اسلحه ثقيله قبل ان
تاتي الانفراجه مع الانباء عن موافقه
المستشار الالماني على تزويد اكياس
بالدبابات وسواء وافق شغل او لا فان بوتن
تلقف هذا التوجه الغربي بغضب كبير من خلال
تمديده بسعينات المستمر الى زياده امدادك
بالاسلحه غضبوا موسكو شمالا الامدادات
الامريكيه ايضا حيث حذر نائب وزير
الخارجيه الروسي ساريا كاف من خطورته وما
يمكن ان تسببه من عواقب وخيمه اذا هي
مواقف لا تزيد الوضع الا توتر وقد يسير
بالحرب نحو سيناريو جديد اكثر حده وهو ما
اسماته موسكو بالحرب الكبير التعبير جاء
على لسان مارجريتا سيمونيا وهي واحده من
اشهر مقدمي البرامج في التليفزيون الحكومي
حيث توقعت ان تبدا هذه الحرب بحلول نهايه
الشتاء بعد الانذارات الاخيره للرئيس
الروسي
لطالما قلت ستكون هناك حرب كبيره بالتاكيد
قبل نهايه فصل الشتاء سيحدث شيء كبير والا
ما كانت لتصدر هذه التحذيرات
السؤال المطروح الان ما هي التحذيرات التي
ارسلها ولم تلتفت اليها اوكرانيا وخلافه
يبدو ان امدادات الاسلحه الغربيه اشعلت
نيرانا غضب روسيا التي لم تعد تستثيق
السخاء الغربي مع اوكرانيا فبينما يسعى
الحلف الاطلسي الى امدادك في الدبابات
تتعد تتعهد واشنطن بمواصله اغلاق اوكرانيا
بالاسلحه وما اثار حفيظه روسيا بشكل اكبر
هو الضغوط التي يمارسها حلف الناتو على
واشنطن من اجل ارسال نظام الصواريخ
الامريكي وهو صاروخ بعيد المدى يبلغ مداه
200 وهو ما يرفضه البيت الابيض حتى الان
خوفا من التصعيد كما ان روسيا تبدو منزعجه
جدا من الاسلحه الامريكيه التي تصل كاف
وبخاصه راجمه الصواريخ هذه مارس التي
الحقت الكثير من الاضرار في صفوف القوات
الروسيه
[موسيقى]